1 en israël on l'a surnommé l'avocat du
diable
satan ou on la qualifie de traître
ennemis internes
elle dit qu'elle prend ça pour un
compliment
depuis presque cinquante ans l'avocate
léa tsemel juive israélienne se consacre
à la sa ble ment à la défense de
palestine hier des militants armés
responsable d'attac aux prisonniers
politiques en passant par des féministes
elles ne reculent devant aucune cause
même quand elle semble perdue d'avancé
en fait peu de choses font peur à léa
tsemel c'est ce que l'on comprend à
travers ce portrait réalisé par rachel
lee jones et philippe belaïch ne veut
pas que que la peur l'arête et elle
pense qu'elle a une obligation morale de
faire ce qu'elle fait donc et donc elle
le fait dans le documentaire on suit
notamment les atsem elle dans la défense
d'ahmed un palestinien de 13 ans accusé
de tentative de meurtre lors d'une
attaque au couteau à jérusalem
l'avocate s'indigne parce qu'elle estime
que le système de justice israélien ne
traite pas les israéliens et les arabes
sur un pied d'égalité par lettre avec
une fraude au réveil femme leah tsemel
dérange en israël à cause de ses
positions très critiques envers les
politiques de l'état hébreu et parce
qu'elle défend des palestiniens auteurs
d' attaque
elle subit régulièrement des menaces
ainsi que les membres de sa famille
alain courage incroyable puisque elle
dit des choses qu'on ne dit pas
en israël simplement parler de
l'occupation comme elle l'est où kamel
le voir de l'occupation en tant que tel
très peu de gens le sont aujourd'hui
dans l'immédiat d'une manière aussi
franche
vous allez nous détailler les nouvelles
lois israéliennes
rien n'a jamais arrêté cette militante
de gauche qui aura 75 ans en juin de
défendre sur toutes les tribunes et
droits de la personne la primauté du
droit et l'égalité de tous devant la
justice des latrines sont là c'est un
des gars me après la zone y at il une
femme de conviction rempli d'espoir et
d'optimisme mais qui se qualifie d'
avocat des causes perdues au
qu'effectivement il n'a pas énormément
de victoires dans ses procès mais là ce
ne serait pas d'accord pour dire est
qu'elle n'a aucun succès malgré tous et
toutes les victoires sont des succès et
comme et donc de réduire la peine d'un
ses clients de faire entendre sa parole
une femme hors de l'ordinaire à
découvrir dans ce documentaire qui a
remporté prix sur prix à l'étranger mais
qui a soulevé une certaine controverse
en israël
ici catherine françois radio canada
montréal